hey guys so we have some pretty exciting
news a while back we got to collaborate
with Samsung and if you guys follow my
snapchat you'll know exactly one yeah
that's pretty cool we had a film crew
follow us for the day so that was
different and we got to make two videos
for each of the products that they
brought over for us to test out don't be
alarmed his hair's not blue yet in this
video she's not a family and she doesn't
change back and forth the colors but
enjoy enjoy enjoy enjoy enjoy enjoy
enjoy
apparently this powerbot has like a
point-and-shoot type of feature oh there
we go
yes I just point at it and then it go
back in whatever I point out pretty much
no sick like a cat I know because cats
would follow that suit you're gonna
protect your credit today parabot you
want to name them I feel like this is
our new pet his name is Sam some haha it
comes back - morning guys today is
Sunday and we are making breakfast we're
gonna power up with Samson today and
they're gonna help us out with our
chores
[Music]
we've been so busy recently we've kind
of neglected this place we need to do
some cleanup some laundry pick some
stuff up your room is a mess
Isaac what's happening usually such a
neat neat little boy laundry and slash
chore day anyways today we're gonna do
some chores it's Sunday how do you feel
about spending your Sunday school choice
you don't like it we can make it fun
have you met Sam yet yeah mommy - Sam
Sam is our new family member of this
home yeah excited to show you so as soon
as you start cleaning up your room once
we finish up breakfast I'll introduce
them to you dang I still some food Oh
hold on I got I just feeling so far away
from the thing I don't know leave me
alone I said build of it like a boy
are you scared so away I'm trying to get
Sam to clean that like kitty food up so
bounced look at that watch
that's awesome skis though can't do that
le Sam can clean up that is freakin cool
pretty impressive
what are you doing I am working on the
things to-do list
Oh busy you know what I'm actually doing
some of the chores that we said we do
like you know vacuuming how about you
handle the actual landing when you're
not doing anything here your honor I'm
gonna get Sam to go over and help Isaac
with his room
I need Santa help me why is he helping
Isaac
[Music]
Isaac laundry time ready mommy don't
want Sam to help me with laundry
so you're gonna help me plunger here you
go here you go
Hey what does go be me means way you
make the shot
Toby three partners from up top you got
a ball okay go for it nice Turner oh
nice three ah
air ball let's Sox baseball time please
Farkle
baseball Kobe
all right last two genes about LeBron
ooh
LeBron it's lesson lesson LeBron works
close enough all right Thank You Isaac I
honestly feel like we had such a
productive weekend because usually on
the weekends we're always working that's
what I'm happy that we were able to have
some help yeah I need help right now or
is you've done like three things or I'm
still in the cellar you're so slow come
on see I end up doing everything anyways
how do you fold this thing oh hi this is
you folding I'm tired I'm tired okay